this year we had a number of students
who were interested who had taken the
class before who are interested in being
involved in some way and acting as
mentors for projects and so what
happened was every week in in our inner
Wednesday afternoon labs the teams of
students would meet with their mentor
and give them an update and get feedback
from them on their on their project
progress I think the one core reason of
doing this this year was to really draw
on the experiences of our mentors having
gone through the entire process in a
previous semester and also being very
passionate about assistive technology
and passionate about how we go about
teaching this class and also to try to
keep teams on track to really understand
the different milestones of different
deadlines and and iterations that are
important to be able to deliver a
successful project it's a successful
prototype by the end of the by the end
of the course I think overall it was
successful in terms of having that
personal interaction with somebody with
some experience to guide teams along in
the in the process